[Musique]
Roseline Bachelot la ministre des
solidarités et l'invité de preuv par TR
bonsoir madame merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation bienvenue sur le
plateau de Public Sénat au moment où
Nicolas Sarkozi que vous avez accompagné
à Bordeaux à lancer sa campagne sur le
thème des fraudes sociales il y a bien
sûr également des impératifs économiques
et un souci d'équité on en parlera avec
moi ce soir et dans un instant Frédéric
du Moulin de l'Agence France Presse
notre partenaire et puis Perin Tarna DEP
Public Sénat Roseline Bachelot pour
rassurer celui que vous appelez votre
petit frère François Fillon attention ce
soir à bien choisir vos mots hein il y a
une petite mise au point du Premier
ministre qui vous a certes défendu
devant les députés UMP hein lorsque vous
peutêtre expquer de quiag vous avez
défendu la déductibilité des dons aux
associations mais vous avez eu un mot
malheureux semble-t-il puisque vous avez
dit que la proposition l'amendement de
l'UMP était
intolérable j'ai simplement à faire à
aider des personnes qui sont en très
grande difficulté et la perspective de
diminuer la déductibilité avait entraîné
une très grande inquiétude chez ces chez
ces
associations on pense au resto du cœur à
la banque alimentaire TER à tous ceux à
toutes celles qui se déploient pour le
logement des plus faibles des plus
démunis pour la prise en charge de leur
santé pour évidemment leur alimentation
et cette perspective leur fait leur
était effectivement intolérable et
causait beaucoup d'inquiétude alors je
comprends la réflexion qui est une
réflexion théorique si je puis dire sur
les niches fiscales mais moi j'ai en
charge ces personnes les plus démunies
et je suis aussi la porte-parole de
leurs inquiétudes cétait tout
d'accord la décisionait éé
parfaitbitré le prier ministre et il
n'était pas question pour le Premier
ministre ni pour la ministre en charge
du budget Valéri pecr de donner un avis
positif du gouvernement sur cet
amendement donc j'étais parfaitement
raccord avec les décisions qui avaient
été prises avec le gouvernement on peut
quand même se poser la question Roseline
bachel alors que l'État est en faillite
est-ce qu'il est tolérable que lorsque
un généreux donateur offre 100 à une
association l'État lui rembourse 75 nous
avons décidé dans le plan de retour à
l'équilibre que nous
sanctuariserions les politiques qui
étaient destinées au plus faible et au
plus démunis c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons décider de continuer
l'augmentation de laallocation d'adultes
handicapés elle aura augmenté de 25 %
pendant le quinquenan de Nicolas Sarkozi
de préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
retraites de continuer l'augmentation du
minimum vieillesse de ne pas toucher à à
la TVA à 55 pour l'alimentation c'est le
principal poste pour les familles les
plus modestes donc voilà il y avait donc
une il y a une cohérence dans le plan de
retour à l'équilibre du gouvernement
protéger les plus faibles et ceci
n'aurait pas été en cohérence avec le
Planon malgré ces cohérences que vous
défendez quand même ce plan de rigueur
faittiquer les familles on y reviendra
parce que quand même ça leur coûtera un
peu d'argent notamment pour celles qui
espéraient une plus forte augmentation
des prestations sociales on y revient
tout à je peux vous répondre mais je
peux vous répondre tout de suiteou il y
a en ce moment des pays qui en Europe
décide de sabrer dans la protection
sociale je vous signale que par exemple
au Royaume-Uni 12 milliards d'économies
sur la la protection sociale des des
prestations qui diminuent de 60 % qui
même sont supprimé nous nous avons
décidé de conserver et de calquer
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat de ces
prestations sur l'augmentation de la
croissance et pas sur l'inflation donc
c'est moins que prévu c'est moins que
prévu mais dans un dans la crise que
nous traversons euh je dois dire que
c'est un bel effort que nous faisons
d'acc alors on y reviendra tout à
l'heure alors lui a pesé ses mots
aujourd'hui vous étiez à ses côtés
Nicolas Sarkozi voler la sécu et trahir
la confiance de tous les Français dit-il
qui n'est pas d'accord bien sûr avec ce
constat mais la gauche estime qu'on
transforme les malades en bouc
émissairire et les syndicat dénonce une
suspicion je je ne comprends pas du tout
cette polémique euh sur une défense
finalement des fraudeurs et des voleurs
il ne s'agit pas de stigmatiser les
honnêtes gens qui ont droit à des
prestations maladies à des prestations
familles à des prestations vieillesse à
des prestations d'Action Social il
s'agit dans un système de protection
sociale qui est le plus généreux du
monde nous consacrons le tiers de notre
richesse de notre produit intérieur brut
à notre protection sociale et nous
souhaitons conserver ce modèle social
finalement lutter contre la fraude ça a
deux effets c'est d'abord bien sûr faire
en sorte que des sommes ne soient pas
indûement versé à ceux qui n'en ont pas
besoin à ceux qui ne n'ont pas de droit
ouvert à ces prestations mais au-delà
c'est sauvegarder notre modèle social
parce que il y a beaucoup de gens qui en
regardant ce modèle social
extraordinairement généreux sont là en
train de se dire mais est-ce que c'est
bien de donner un revenu minimum au
pauvres est-ce qu'on devrait pas baisser
le taux de remboursement de certaines
prestations maladie et finalement est-ce
qu'on devrait pas mettre les allocations
familiales sous conditions de ressources
il y a beaucoup de gens qui veulent
attaquer ce modèle social et qui le font
parfois sur l'argument de la fraude moi
et avec bien sûr le président de la
République et Premier ministre nous
voulons sauvegarder notre modèle social
et lutter contre la fraude c'est c'est
un moyen de le préserver mais on peut
aller beaucoup plus loin Roseline
Bachelot parce que la fraude aux arrêt
malades par exemple c'est 4 milliards
d'euros et celle des patrons qui ont
recours au travail au noir c'est trois
fois plus et puis la fraude fiscale
alors là c'est 40 milliards mais vous
avez mais vous avez raison il y a la
fraude la fraude nous le disons avec
Xavier Bertran avec qui nous nous
pilotons nous nous attaquons à tous les
types de fraude par exemple dans le plan
dans l'expérimentation que j'ai mené
auprès de 14 caisses d'allocation
familiale et qui s'est terminé au mois
de septembre et que nous allons
généraliser nous avons ciblé le travail
dissimulé comme une des priorités donc
véritablement la fraude aux cotisations
et avec le président de la République
nous avons rencontré un certain nombre
d'acteurs salariés des patrons aussi des
la fraude du travail dissimulé la fraude
des patrons qui ne déclare pas leur
salariés et ne verseent donc pas de
cotisation sociale à gauche en tous les
cas on estime que Nicolas Sarkozi avec
bah son discours de Bordeaux a choisi
ces thèmes de campagne un peu comme un
appel du pied à la Droite populaire et
même aux électeurs du fr national qui
sont c'est vrai peut-être plus sensibles
encore que les
autres à la question de la fraude est-ce
que est-ce que c'est çael la la lecture
politique le discours de Nicolas Sarkozy
était un discours très important qui
était un discours qui concernait toute
la protection sociale et toute
philosophie de la protection sociale
c'était un discours de président de la
République parce que quand la protection
sociale d'un pays emploie le tiers des
revenus de ces pays de ce pays c'est
très important d' par euh j'ai dit les
forces les forces centrifuges qui mais
pourquoi voulez-vous que je je taxe
d'arrière-pensée parler de la protection
sociale pour un président de la
République c'est un discours que Nicolas
Sarkozy fait en continu enfin on se
trouve effectivement dans une période de
précampagne électorale présid le
président de la République n'a pas
encore dit ses intentions moi je fais
pas de procès d'intention à mes
adversaires il développ il développent
leur argumentation nous développons les
ntres et nous défendons et nous
défendons notre politique pourquoi nous
faisons cela et et et les les raisons
qui nous qui nous guident d'accord voilà
vos adversaires parlons du parti un mot
sur le Parti socialiste quand même Ros
bachel parce que il y a aussi l'annonce
aujourd'hui de l'obligation de travail
qui est acté pour les bénéficiaires du
RSA ça va se mettre en place au moment
où l'UMP diffuse un tracte contre le
Parti social un tra qui tire à boulet
rouge contre le parti du laxisme et de
l'assistana on est bien dans les thèmes
de campagne là aussi hein alors je veux
peut-être revenir d'un mot sur le
contrat sur le RSA puisque j'ai j'ai
décidé de proposer au bénéficiaaires du
RSA par
l'intermédiaire des conseils généraux
d'un certain nombre de conseils généraux
expérimentateurs je reçois d'ailleurs
les 11 premiers conseil président de
conseil général expérimentateur demain
de gauche alors hein à gauche est
partenaire là ah mais tous ceux qui
veulent venir bénéficier de ce contrat
le peu bien entendu il y a pas de
couleur politique dans dans dans ce
choix euh il y a la moitié à peu près
c'est moitié moitié he pour les conseils
généraux euh donc euh véritablement nous
nous rendons compte qu'il y a des
publics très éloignés de l'emploi pour
lequel le contrat d'insertion classique
qui fait 20h c'est déjà beaucoup un
mi-temps c'est déjà beaucoup et en
partant d'ailleurs d'une expérimentation
d'une préexpérimentation qui avait été
faite par Hervé guemard en sa voix et
qui avait expérimenté un contrat d'une
journée c'était très intéressant donc
nous proposons cela pour ces publics
très éloignés de l'emploi alors bien
entendu il signne un contrat de retour à
l'emploi et c'est s'ils ne respectent
pas leur les obligations qu'ils ont
signé qu'ils sont éventuellement
pénalisé par le président du conseil
général d'ord est-ce que c'est une
réponse donc au laxisme supposé du Parti
socialiste et c'est surtout une réponse
humaine pas une réponse au laxisme c'est
finalement proposer à ce aux acteurs de
l'insertion un certain nombre d'outils
moi je j'ai en face de moi des publics
parfois très abîmés qui ont des des
difficultés familiales des difficultés
de santé qui sont profondément
désinsérés qui n'ont pas les acquis
fondamentaux de la lecture de l'écriture
on dit à à ces personnes écoutez comme
ça si comme si c'était facile c'est déjà
difficile pour des gens qui ont toutes
les cartes en main vous imaginez pour
ces personnes leur difficulté moi je je
veux proposer aux acteurs de l'insertion
des outils d'insertion d'cord voilà avec
donc bah ces 7 heur hebdomadaires qui
sont propos s la forme d'un contrat avec
des conseillers généraux de gauche de
droite ne et ça donnera 132 €
supplémentaires par mois à ses public
donc c'est pas une contrepartie du RSA
c'est un salaire
130 € en plus moyen c'est ça on
travaille pas pour rienà alors euh on
parlait des prestations sociales dans la
hausse va être ralentie les familles
s'inquiètent Roseline Bachelot je vois
que le nouveau centre fait également des
propositions he comme la gauche le
nouveau centre fait des propositions
pour épargner donc cette hausse des
prestations familiales qui sont remises
en cause par par par le plan de rigueur
il propose de baisser plutôt la dotation
aux collectivités locales vous en pensez
c'est une bonne idée une alternative vu
cette proposition du Nouveau Centre nous
ce que nous avons dit à à l'Assemblée
nationale au parlementaires nous avons
bâti un plan équilibré mais si vous
préférez à l'intérieur de ce plan dans
dans dans dans la masse à la fois des
recettes et et des économies si vous
voulez rééquilibrer nous sommes très
vous pensez bien que la min la Ministre
en charge la ministre en charge de la
famille si ma foi cette proposition
recueille l'assentiment du Parlement je
suis comme le premier ministre qui
d'ailleurs assista à cette réunion et
qui a dit pourquoi pas donc voilà
pourquoi pas en tous les cas pour les
familles bénéficiant d'êide social ce
plan de rigueur a un coup ouiine
Bachelot il faut quand même le
reconnaître que nous présente Paul
Bouffard avant d'accueillir Frédéric du
Moulin de la
FP une rigueur en forme de coup de Massu
pour les familles tout d'abord gel du
barê de l'impôt sur le revenu en clair
les Français qui se verront augmenter
paieront plus d'impôts ils passeront
plus rapidement d'une tranche à l'autre
car les seuils ne suivront pas
l'inflation des recettes supplémentaires
de 1,7 milliards en 2012 50 % des
contribuable touché et toujours la même
cible le pouvoir d'achat on fait des
économies en tapant sur les familles on
sait aujourd'hui que quand on on touche
au pouvoir d'achat des familles on
touche à la consommation et donc lorsque
la consommation ralentit ça veut dire
que c'est l'activité qui est ralenti et
donc une augmentation automatique de du
chômage une austérité qui frappe aussi
les prestations sociales objectif dans
ce domaine économiser 400 millions
d'euros en 2012 principal poste de
rigueur les allocation familiale
imaginons un ménage avec deux enfants de
7 et 14 ans en 2011 ils ont touché 1933
€ sans la réforme le couple aurait vu
progresser leur aide de 2,3 % mais rigur
oblige la progression est gelée à 1 %.
au final un manque à gagné de 30 € une
petite somme mais à la Confédération
Syndicale des Familles 1 € est 1 €. pour
familles pour 3 € il y avit des familles
qui seront en impayé de loyer même une
petite somme je pense que 3
€ sur la symbolique c'est assez fort
c'est pas le le le le le numéraire qui
compte c'est le symbolique qui est assez
fort pourquoi prendre 3 € dans la poche
des ménages quand on peut
récupérer 12 milliards ailleurs pas de
coup de pouce pour les écoliers le prix
des Fournitures gonfle mais les familles
verront leurs allocations rentrées
scolaires progresser seulement de 1 % en
2011 elles avaient augmenté d'1,5 %.
enfin il faudra aussi serrer la vis dans
le domaine de la santé face à
l'austérité les mutuels risquent de
répercuter une hausse des tarifs de 4,7
% sur les
patients voilà Frédéric du Moulin de la
FP nous a rejoint Frédéric donc Madame
bonsoir bonsoir donc on est en plein
plan de rigueur puisque le mot
maintenant n'est plus vraiment tabou
dans votre famille politique est-ce
qu'on peut être réélu selon vous sur la
rigueur alors moi je veux dire que c'est
pas uniquement une question de
sémantique je suis pas d'accord avec ce
mot parce que qu'est-ce que ça signifie
on le voit dans un certain nombre de
pays étrangers qu'est-ce que ça
signifie je merci mais je vous avez
invité Roseline Bachelot hein je crois
donc je peux utiliser mes mots qui sont
ceux que je choisis et et et mes
opinions mes convictions je veux dire
simplement que la rigueur c'est diminuer
les salaires des f fonctionnaire comme
on le fait par exemple en Irlande où il
baisse de 15 % c'est diminuer les
pensions comme on le fait dans un
certain nombre de pays 20 % en Grèce en
en
Espagne aussi on baisse les pensions
c'est c'est augmenté massivement
massivement les taxes donc c'est ça la
rigueur nous ce que nous voulons c'est
certes être si la la rigueur d'être
rigoureux de bien mener de de bien mener
le le le vaisseau de l'État oui
certainement mais moi ce que je veux
dire je parle bien de plan de tour à
l'équilibre nous voulons passer entre
deux intégrismes finalement c'est simple
il y a ceux qui veulent saigner le
malade et qu'il meurent guéris
c'est-à-dire de dire il faut tout faire
pour lutter contre les déficits et et et
vraiment cogné pour ce retour à
l'équilibre le plus rapidement possible
nous ne voulons pas
aé majorité non mais on a vu par exemple
les soutiens de Monsieur Barou être sur
C être sur cette ligne libéral éalement
et et nous voyons bien que nous ne
voulons pas le président la République
ne veut pas bloquer la machine
économique et de l'autre côté les
socialistes et la gauche direent et
allons-y continuons les dépenses et
augmentons les impôts donc nous voulons
passer entre ces deux intégrismes mettre
la France sur le retour à l'équilibre
sans bloquer la machine économique c'est
bien un plan de retour à l'équilibre que
pensez-vous de l'attitude du du Sénat de
gauche justement qui a complètement
détricoté le projet de budget pour pour
la pour la sécurité sociale que j'ai été
ébahi par les débats qui se sont
déroulés par les teneurs des débats qui
se sont déroulés mes vous savez on avait
l' on avait l'habitude à l'Assemblée
nationale ou au Sénat j'ai l'habitude
d'être dans l'opposition j'aiété 14 ans
parlementaires 10 ans dans l'opposition
4 ans dans la majorité donc je sais ce
que c'est que d'être parlementaire
d'opposition j'ai jamais vu ça une
opposition
systématique je voyais je développais
par exemple hier un certain nombre
d'argum nous parlions du médicosocial
avec des arguments qui tenaient vraiment
pas la route et je voyais le regard de
mes interlocuteurs qui me disait mais
vous avez raison effectivement si nous
étions au pouvoir on le ferait pas mais
on est dans l'opposition on s'oppose là
je crois vraiment que bon je je je
dirais je je passe sur sur ça je pense
que c'est un début d'opposition au Sénat
et que sans doute on va on on va revenir
à des choses plus raisonnables du moins
je l'espère parce que il y a des gens de
qualité hein je vois pas par exemple le
sénateur Jean daudini ne m'avait pas
habitué auparavant quand il était dans
l'opposition à à une vision aussi aussi
brutal j'allais dire borner mais le mot
on va le dire va encore dépasser ma
pensée mais on a mot vous dépasse
parfois vous disiez il y a quelques
minutes donc raisonnable mais donc
justement vous vousmême n'avez pas
vousmême n'avez pas exclu qu'il y a un
troisème une troisième vague de ce plan
on peut appeler
d'austérité qu'est-ce qu'on peut
demander ensuite donc en terme de
sacrifice d'abord nous avons nous avons
des marges de
manœuvre ce plan de retour ce plan de
retour à l'équilibre il part d'une
analyse sérieuse de la situation nous
avons pris des perspectives de
croissance moyenne par rapport aux
différents experts qui nous entourent le
FMI 10 1,4 % la Commission européenne
dis 6 nous avons pris 1 % nous avons vu
que les meilleurs experts peuvent se
tromper ils avaient prévu pour le 3e
trimestre 0 % de croissance notre taux
de croissance est à 0,4 % divine
surprise pour ces fameux experts donc
nous avons des perspectives réalistes
nous menons ce plan de retour à
l'équilibre à travers les décisions du
24 août les décisions que nous venons de
prendre mais aussi des décisions qui on
été prises dans le ce qu'on appelle le
PLF la loi de finances pour 2012 la loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale et
nous avons constitué une réserve de
précaution de 6 milliards la ministre du
Budget Valéri pecr l'a confirmé donc
nous avons une vision réaliste des
choses et quand on regarde bien tout ce
qui est fait on a vraiment l'impression
que c'est une course contre la monde qui
est engagée et qu' qu' s'agit pour le
gouvernement de faire coûte que coûte en
sorte que le la note triple A ne soit
pas dégradée d'ici le mois de mai c'est
un petit peu ça quand même il s'agit pas
de ça la note triple A elle est une
conséquence elle est une constatation
d'un certain nombre de club d'experts
nous ce que nous voulons c'est ten nos
engagements nos engagements c'est de
suivre un plan de réduction des déficits
qui nous amène à 3 % en 2013 et qui nous
amène à 0 % de de déficit en 2016 et
nous sommes en avance sur nos
perspectives de retour à l'équilibre
donc nous suivons extrêmement bien notre
cadencier de retour à l'équilibre sur
2010 sur 2011 et demain sur 2012 à 4,5 %
2012 et 3 % et 3 % en 2013 nous n'avons
aucune raison de modifier dans notre
perspective nationale nous n'avons
aucune raison de modifier les
fondamentaux de notre démarche vous
disiez vous-même tout à l'heure on est
presque dans la campagne présidentielle
ça avance maintenant oui effectivement
donc et vous devez être heureuse parce
que donc Nicolas Sarkozi connaît un
regain dans les sondages alors que
François Hollande a un petit peu une
quelques difficultés on le voit
actuellement est-ce que vous vous diriez
comme certains de vos cègues qui sont
pas tendre avec lui est-ce que vous le
le qualifieriez de Babar vous
aussi écoutez je trouve qu'on est très
gentil dans l'opposition dans la enfin
on est très méchant dans l'opposition et
très gentil dans la majorité avec
François Hollande quand on voit comment
les socialistes traite le président de
la République le Premier ministre le
gouvernement avec une brutalité avec des
injures vraiment monsieur chattel a
utilisé le terme Babar qui est un
éléfant que chacun parle avec S ces mots
je l'ai revendiqué il y a un instant qui
est un terme bien sympathique j'ai adoré
Babar quand j'étais
enfant derrière tout ça mais je ne suis
pas céleste mais je veux dire non mais
ce qui est délicieux c'est d'entendre
les amis de Monsieur Holland parler de
lui parce que nous nous sommes
relativement gentils agréables et
urbains mais eux ils se conduisent avec
une brutalité parce que ce sont les gens
je vous signal avec lesquels Monsieur
Hollande va devoir gouverner
demain le capitaine de P ô c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est Monsieur Mélenchon vous
avez vu ce qu'a dit Monsieur conbandit
dans le journal Libération monsieur
monsieurand est en train de se
ségoléniser madame jolie tient des
propos extrêmement peu
agréables une secondeêement peu agréable
sur monsieur sur monsieur nous nous
sommes dans l'opposition moi je viens
pas gémir je
viens nous sommes dans l'opposition
monsieur Holland dire nous sommes dans
l'opposition à Monsieur Hollande nous
sommes dans C C opposition écoutez nous
attaquons Monsieur Hollande der derrière
tout ça on a quand même l'impression
quand monsieur Copé parle de manque de
courage donc là il y a Babar il y a
aussi il y a quand même la volonté de
l'UMP d'installer dans l'opinion le fait
que Monsieur Holland n'aurait pas la
stature d'un homme d'État j'outeout nous
faisons nous ne faisons finalement que
relayer la vision de Martine aub
j'ajoute là ça n'est pas la vision de
Martin auri la vision de François Fillon
l'assem nation vous étonnez qu'on dis
pas bien de Monsieur vous êtes une
fraîcheur est est-ce que selon vous est-
est- François Fillon dit que François
Hollande et le Parti socialiste porte
atteinte aux intérêts de la France avec
cette politique de dénigrement et puis
avec l'accord passé avec les ver sur le
nucétrang l'éanger oui je suis d'accord
sur le fait que devant la difficulté de
la situation euh le la façon dont
Monsieur Hollande a baissé les bras
devant une perspective de dégradation de
la note de la France même en se
demandant s'il ne la souhaitait pas la
façon dont il l'a formulé était pour le
moins extrêmement curieuse vraiment
c'est extrêmement inquiétant il faut que
sur un certain nombre de choses dans une
situation si difficile et en particulier
la crédibilité de la France à
l'international on trouve le minimum de
consensus autour du président de la
République vous parlez justement du
courage avec les mesures annoncées par
le président la République et le
gouvernement euh on a vu donc ce weekend
un mariage célébré donc un mariage
illégal célébré entre deux hommesou
c'était pas un mariage cé plutôt une
cérémonie on sait on connaî votre combat
notamment pour le paxù vous avez été
quand même très minoritaire dans votre
camp donc est-ce que le courage selon
vous c'est aussi par exemple pour le
président de la République de se
déclarer favorable au mariage homosexuel
en 2012 je prends pas d'engagement pour
le président de la République il est
assez grand pour dire au moment de la
campagne électorale car je ne doute pas
que cette question sera évoquée quels
sont ses choix et quels sont les choix
qu'il propose à la France pour moi
depuis très longtemps vous connaissez
mes opinions sur ce sujet je suis pour
le mariage entre deux personnes de même
sexe je ne Renis pas mes engagements
bien au contraire j'auraiis l'occasion
de le réexprimer dans la campagne
électorale je le fais dans le respect
des convictions de chacun je ne pense
pas par exemple qu'on est homophobe
parce qu'on n'est pas pour le mariage
entre deux personnes de même sexe chacun
la vision religieuse anthropologique et
sociologique du mariage moi je pense que
le mariage a profondément évolué il est
maintenant d'abord une déclaration
d'amour entre deux personnes avant
d'être un acte politique ou un acte
religieux il est une proclamation
sociale d'un attachement entre deux
êtres qui s'inscrit dans la durée et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
souhaite qu'il soit ouvert aux personnes
de même sexe mais ce qui est vrai c'est
que le Président de la République quand
il était encore le candidat Nicolas
Sarkozi en 2006-27 s'était engagé pour
une union civile spécifique qui n'a
jamais vu le jour oui alors c'est c'est
un sujet sur lequel nous pouvons avancer
et sur lequel d'ailleurs travaille ma
secrétaire d'État Claude Greff votre
mesure est-ce que vous seriez favorable
au vote des étrangers installés en
France depuis 5 ans aux élections
locales hein c'est vous êtes là vous
êtes donc vous êtes contre cette mesure
euh au fait où en est la la réforme de
la dépendance Roseline Bachelot elle est
abandonnée définitivement la la réformme